I now have peripheral neuropathy from the chemo, I think that was supposed to say, from the chemo.
What supplements are other things can I do to help with it?
So peripheral neuropathy from chemo is a toxicity neuropathy,
meaning that a toxin that stays in your system has the chance of damaging nerves.
Why does it damage peripheral nerves?
Because the blood low to get the toxin out of the periphery just from a gravitational standpoint,
the toxin is going to have a better chance of settling in one's periphery,
in the hands and in the feet, and thereby damaging the nerves.
The longer a toxin is in the vicinity of cells, those cells can be damaged.
And if those are nerve cells, those nerve cells can be damaged.
Usually it's the schwan cells, which are the same as the myelin,
sheath cells in the upper motor neuron cells in the brain,
and the lower motor neurons in the periphery, those are called schwan cells.
Usually those are damaged causing peripheral neuropathy.
How do you heal from peripheral neuropathy?
Well, your B vitamins are beneficial, B6 is a beneficial supplement.
But there's other things other than supplements that are more beneficial.
So there's a little machine called a rebuilder,
and that is FDA-approved little apparatus.
It looks like the size of a tens unit, if you ever used a tens unit,
but it puts out frequency very specific to nerve reconstruction.
So you put that rebuilder, how it's used.
It comes with rubber pads and not stick them, pads.
And you put the rubber pads in water and two separate tubs.
You get one of those split tubs that they sell at Walmart or Target,
and you put your feet in the water similar to eye and cleanse,
but it won't change the color or anything,
because you're just putting frequencies to stimulate nerve, low and nerve growth.
You can put your hands in that tub,
and then you like to have somebody else turn it up, obviously.
And you turn it up to tolerance, there's instruction that come with a rebuilder.
It is one of the only FDA devices for peripheral neuropathy.
It's a great device.
We sell a lot of them,
especially when we were doing more brain-based therapy,
we sold a lot of them to people,
because it is a great brain-based therapy.
It stimulates the cerebellum in the frontal lobe,
even if a person doesn't have peripheral neuropathy.
So it can be really good for people with Alzheimer's
and Parkinson's as well,
but it's really a tool for peripheral neuropathy.
Done, at least once a day,
a 15-bit of sex session can be extremely beneficial.
If you have access to a PEMF machine,
put on a pulse, electromagnetic frequency,
that can be very beneficial for peripheral neuropathy as well.
So those two tools are rebuilder
and a PEMF are the best tools for peripheral neuropathy
and then B vitamins are a good nutrient to help the nerves as well.